Is Crimea's
Russian land
story
actually true?
First receipt,
Russia's own
1774 treaty
calls Crimea an
independent
khanate.
Jump to 1783,
Catherine the
Great
annexes Crimea.
But even by
Russia's
1897 census,
the majority of
the people living
there were
Tatars, not
Russians.
Then the
heartbreak.
In 1944, Stalin
deports over
200,000 Tatars.
Families gone
overnight.
1954, Khrushchev
transfers Crimea
to Ukraine,
mostly for shared
water and
power lines.
No Soviet
republic objects.
1994, Russia
signs the
Budapest
Memorandum,
promising to
respect Ukraine's
borders.
Crimea included.
So Crimea,
Russian?
That's hype, not
history.
Much like if you
learn
something new.